foreign
Dallas hi Daniela how are you
hey Michael I'm so grateful to be
well honored to have you how can we help
yes so I'm wondering if I should sell my
condo because the HOA is really
and I wonder if I should sell it
sell it the rest of my Dad wow watch the
HOA so high
what's the condo worth
um I think so
and I owe 122 000 on it
okay I'm um
as a homeowner
uh if I'm you I I am by the end of the
day I want some information from these
people
but they're doing it the money yeah
that's asinine what is going on a 250
000 condo with a 650 I mean that sounds
like a two million dollar property or
three million dollars right exactly and
it's like I'm in Texas like what's going
on
well I mean you could do it stupid's in
Texas too but um but you know I mean wow
yeah yeah I want to find out what's
under this and you know did they jacket
how long have you been there
um since 2018 so I thought that was 450
and they just literally putting up like
100 every year so now we're at 6.50 and
so these I have these like assessments
that we would pay every other month so
now they just tacked it all together
every month every month right
so now there's no or the condo were they
doing a major renovation like parking
lot replacement or roof replacement or
something that's the thing I haven't
seen anything happen in like the
president is probably complaining about
it people are trying to like run for
office I'm not the only one concerned
about it
um if you got this point I just feel
like these years people have been
complaining nothing have happened so I'm
like I don't even own the land like is
it worth continuously
you know owning this condom or should I
step out of it well the problem you've
got to find out about this anyway
because this devalues your condo
nobody wants to buy 250 000 condo with
this ridiculous HOA fee so it's going to
make your condo not worth as much
right so you've got to find out what the
Flip's going on to having maybe it's
going on for one more year because
they're building up a war chest to go do
the roofs or something like that but you
don't have to be by bylaws very
transparent oh yeah you have the right
to know exactly where the money is yeah
you have to be able to they're supposed
to document
everything so yeah you should be able to
pull yeah I want to see I want to see a
copy of the financials and explain to me
why the flip this is double what it
should and minutes from the meetings I
mean all of that I think you you need to
pull all of that and see yeah see what's
going on because that is that is strange
but just say for your sake Danielle like
say it is like well sorry this is just
what it is and
you know I don't know yes I would sell I
would get out of there because it's
being poorly managed yes oh I'm so
excited to hear this I like that okay
I'll do the first step but yeah because
you've got to have you've got to have an
explanation for your buyer otherwise I
don't want to buy it if I'm the buyer I
don't I don't want to walk into this
yeah because that's a red flag I mean if
you just say I have high and you mean 25
dollars high but this sounds to me like
it's double what it should be
um I mean we own a property for instance
that the HOA fees uh include a golf
course and several other things and it's
only 750 and the properties in that
neighborhood are uh five to twenty
million dollars
just to give you an idea that's how
stupid this number is
so um that that's just nuts and and so
you know and there's a lot of amenities
built into that's what I'm saying like
country club type stuff yeah schools and
clubhouses and yeah yeah and so into
that it's an entire development yeah
little city so obviously you're going to
pay more but for a 250 000 condo to be
paying as much as you're paying
attention yeah that's just nuts so I'm
going to want to know more and the
problem is is that
that's I hate HOAs I just hate them this
is such a free spirit thing to say I
don't even know how much are Winston
pays it's not much it's always in our
butt
I know but no I'm sorry we don't live
with a community with a golf course
that's not what the point was the point
is you guys are in a very efficiently
run neighborhood Winston and I have
talked about this it was not it was not
the the fact that you're living in the
slums
obviously not not as expensive as mine
so uh
yeah oh my gosh
all you free spirits up there it's okay
if you have a nerd spouse and they run
every little thing I just think in my
head I was like I need to go to my every
dollar budget and see how much our HOA
fees are because I'm like I don't even
yeah I'm just we're members of a whole
bunch of HOAs and none of them are fun
so um none of them you just don't like
being told what to do
I don't like paying you know and then
being told what to do that's exactly
right by people who don't have anything
else to do with their lives you should
run for your board no thank you
and you should you should I have found
to never waste my time serve your
community
serve your community
time talents is the way to give in life
and Dave we'll have to find another way
to be a good way to serve we'll have to
find another way day for president day
for president you might see signs okay
throughout 2024 irrigated serve your
country you sound like the OC I'm more
likely to serve my country
and both of them are not around the
Housewives one of the intros the OC is
like you know gated community all bougie
you should be you should be a part of
the Real Housewives too
we'll fit right in
I should be a real housewife or use
in that cup what
what are you drinking over here this is
the Ramsay show